should the Supreme Court defer to the
will of the majority and and and respect
the will of majority and therefore
uphold most democratically enacted laws
or does the Constitution empower the
courts to act as a check on the other
branches of government and then to act
and act aggressively and act in even an
anti-democratic fashion when when the
majority has has overstepped its
boundaries so we talked a lot about
ideas and the power of ideas this
weekend and we've heard about the power
of ideas in terms of change in
government policy the power of ideas in
terms of influencing the Supreme Court
and so I'm going to continue that theme
and talk about the power of ideas on the
Supreme Court and legal philosophies and
how they have affected some of the
biggest Supreme Court cases in US
history so I just let me begin by I went
to read two quotations that sort of set
up the themes but I'm going to talk
about the first comes from a letter
written in the year nineteen twenty by
Supreme Court justice Oliver Wendell
Holmes jr. and he writes and in this
letter i should say Holmes is talking
about his philosophy of judging what he
believes the role of a judge that the
role of a judge should be and he writes
quote if my fellow citizens want to go
to hell I will help them it's my job the
the second quote comes from Chief
Justice John Roberts in his 2012
decision upholding the Patient
Protection and Affordable Care Act this
is the Obamacare case 2012 John Roberts
writes quote it is not our job to
protect the people from the consequences
of their political choices so in other
words in Obamacare Roberts might have
said let the people go to hell you voted
for Obama you you get obamacare so you
know at a glance this is a spare of
strange bedfellows Roberts is this elite
conservative legal thinker and Oliver
Wendell Holmes is this progressive era
justice who made his name arguing that
the court should defer to the elected
branches
government and should should uphold most
democratically enacted economic
regulations the progressive regulations
of the time so what is a conservative
like Roberts doing invoking this
Progressive Era hero homes in the
Obamacare case well the answer is that
these men both are proponents or were in
Holmes's case proponents of the
philosophy of judicial restraint or
judicial deference and this is the idea
that the supreme court and the courts
are the least democratic branch of our
government and as a result they owe
extra respect or deference to the
elected branches to the democratically
accountable branches you know the
president elected by the people Congress
elected by the people state lawmakers
legislators elected by the people of
those states and so when a
constitutional question comes before the
Supreme Court dealing one of one of
these democratically enacted statutes
the judges should put the thumb on the
scale on the side of the government on
the side of lawmakers then and tip the
balance that way so this is this idea of
judicial deference and although it
starts off as a philosophy of the
progressives and Holmes is writing
during the Progressive air and the
progressives love him he is a hero to
the progressives he's hugely influential
in the New Deal when the New Deal
triumphs of the Supreme Court nineteen
thirty-eight thirty-seven thirty-eight
Holmes's views are vindicated are are
accepted by the majority and they're
still with us today but judicial
restraint or deference is also become a
touchstone of modern conservatives in
the last forty years the conservative
legal movement has has rallied around
this call in many ways and and Robert
Bork late Robert Bork who was Ronald
Reagan of course nominated to the
Supreme Court and was a federal judge a
very distinguished conservative legal
scholar fork was a proponent of this
Oliver Wendell Holmes style judicial
deference and in his book the tempting
of America Bork wrote quote in wide
areas of life majorities are entitled to
rule if they wish simply because they
are majorities for Bork that meant the
Supreme Court should butt out of those
disputes those wide areas of life let
the majority rule so this approach the
homes Bork approach this is what John
Roberts invokes in the Obamacare case
the biggest case of his of his term
now obviously many conservatives were
not too happy with that ruling and of
course libertarians were outraged about
it also because that is one way for
judges to approach these questions but
there is another way and this other way
has been associated very closely with
the libertarian legal movement which is
what I call it in the book it's that's
arisen in the last 30 or 40 years and
and David mentioned the Institute for
justice they are pioneers in this work
Manny klausner who's here with us he is
manny has been has been a libertarian
lawyer fighting these fights the Cato
Institute Center for Constitutional
studies has been involved in these
fights and what the libertarian legal
movements view is they say well wait a
minute you know the Constitution is a
Liberty document it protects a broad
range of individual rights and it
imposes strict limits on government
power and so therefore is the job of the
courts to police the other branches of
government to strike down government
overreach and that of course was the
view of the legal challengers in the
Obamacare case they they lose because
Roberts invokes this progressive
doctrine of judicial deference so my
book is about the battle between these
this clash of visions and that's why I
call it the long war because it's a it's
a it's an intellectual battle that's
been going on for a century and a half
and as I say it shaped many of the
biggest cases in our in our legal
history we see it in the Progressive Era
and the New Deal era with a question is
what is the government's role in the
economy how much power does Congress
have under the Commerce Clause to
regulate economic affairs how much power
to the states have and the progressives
and in do dealers said well that power
is practically unlimited and the courts
have no business stepping in and
conservative and sort of proto
libertarian judges and lawyers of the
time they wanted the courts to act and
the courts did act against some
progressive laws against some new deal
regulations but but that view ultimately
is not triumphant and we see this this
this intellectual battle continuing
throughout the 20th century and the
battles over civil rights voting rights
school desegregation where once again
the question is should the court act to
the court act against Democratic
majorities on the state level does the
Fourteenth Amendment empower the courts
to strike down overreaching state laws
we heard about that today at lunch when
there is the court where there's the
issue of the Fourteenth Amendment voting
rights the civil rights movement and and
that was once again these this question
of how much deference is owed to these
local official
and then of course it's as I said in the
Obamacare case we saw it in recent gun
rights cases where a district of
columbia versus heller mcdonald or city
of chicago where local authorities said
look you know the Second Amendment
that's fine but we understand that the
conditions we get a lot of crime down
here we got a lot of gun violence and
the Supreme Court should not be should
not be minding our business should not
be second-guessing the gun control
regulations that local officials and
state officials had had come up with and
the libertarian view and I should say
that those really were libertarian cases
the lawyers who argued in one those
Second Amendment cases are libertarian
lawyers Clark Neely from this do for
justice Allen gura Bob Leavy from the
Cato Institute they conceived litigated
and and won those in those cases
bringing this libertarian philosophy the
Constitution is a Liberty document the
second amendments of Liberty provision
of Bill of Rights and it limits limits
the government so so that's the the
broad theme of the whole book but what I
wanted to do tonight is talk just
briefly about two cases where these
philosophies are really sort of evident
so the first case that illustrates these
theories is called Meyer vs nebraska
this is the Supreme Court decides in
this case in your 19 23 and the backdrop
to this case is world war one America
we're at we're at war with Germany and
and the homefront all sorts of really
ugly anti-german sentiment pops up
there's a jingoistic behavior and some
of this in historical you know looking
back is sort of comical there was a
movement to rename the hamburger as the
Liberty sandwich you know so some of
this weekend we can laugh at but then
there were there were ugly things that
happened to there's lynchings of German
Americans German immigrants and in the
state of Nebraska the state legislature
pets Legislature passed a law that made
it illegal to educate young children in
a foreign language public and private
schools and the the target of this
legislation was the state's lutheran
parochial schools German immigrants in
the state were sending their kids to
Lutheran schools where the teachers and
the students were frequently speaking
German so there is a man named Robert
Myer he's a Bible teacher at the school
teaches the Bible in German to little
kids and he's now criminal under under
state law and he he says this is
unconstitutional this violates my rights
violates the right
these parents he takes the case to the
state Supreme Court he loses the state
Supreme Court says he salya Tory purpose
of the law is clear they sought no
problem with it he takes it to the
federal courts to the Supreme Court and
he wins and the supreme court issues
what I think is one of the a really
resounding libertarian statement in our
legal history it's the opinions by
Justice James McReynolds who's later
kind of infamous is one of the four
horsemen which is this negative term
given to the conservative justices who
voted regularly against the New Deal the
Liberals at the time called them the
Four Horsemen of reaction well in this
case McReynolds writes this great
statement about liberty he says the word
Liberty in the Fourteenth Amendment this
is a due process clause quote denotes
not merely freedom from bodily restraint
but also the right of the individual to
contract to engage in any of the common
occupations of life to marry establish a
home and bring up children so you see
economic Liberty is there liberty of
contract right to work in a common
occupation but also writes of families
to marry to raise children so of course
our old friend Justice Holmes is on the
Supreme Court at the time so he descents
in the case he says that he sees that he
doesn't see anything in the constitution
that would prevent the state legislature
from experimenting on its young citizens
in this way he said let the majority
have its way that's his view in this
case so the second case I'll talk about
a little more recent and I think it'd be
a little more familiar to probably a lot
of you is called kilo versus the city of
New London this is a case in 2005
eminent domain property rights case
litigated by the Institute for justice
and you know so the backdrop ticked
aquilo is well first of the
constitutional issue is the Fifth
Amendment something called the takings
clause which says that the government
cannot take public property for public
use less it pays just compensation so
what's a public use well traditionally a
public use is if the government wants to
build a broad a road or a bridge or a
tunnel and you know some landowners in
the way and they pay them out of the
public treasury and then they and they
built the road the city of New London
Connecticut in this case they had a
broader sense of what this power would
allow them to do the Pfizer
pharmaceutical corporation was building
a new research and development facility
in New London and there was this
neighborhood right next to it called
Fort Trumbull and this was a love
working class a well-tended neighborhood
you know not not a fancy neighborhood
but like a working-class neighborhood in
good shape and the city thought wouldn't
it be great if we could just send the
bulldozers in flat in the neighborhood
give the land to private developers and
they will put up a hotel and some
restaurants and some upscale amenities
and that would bring in more tax dollars
and that would benefit all of us the
public of New London and we should be
able to do this under the takings power
and I mean obviously people live in this
neighborhood didn't think that was a
good idea and there's woman named
Suzette kilo she had this little pink
house that had a review of the river
that she loved and so she formed the
backbone of a local property rights
movement that fought back against this
this government action the city of New
London fought him they fought it out in
court they end up at the Supreme Court
in the city of New London's argument is
looked at the what counts as a public
use that's really up to us to decide
that is a question for the legislature
not for the court is we say you know we
know the conditions here we know what we
need this is a economic revitalization
plan it's in the it's in the best
interest and this is really the kind of
judgment that the courts have no
business getting involved in obviously
Suzette kilo the Institute for justice
took a very different view they said
look the public use clause has teeth
that means what it says and this is this
is not a public use and this is this
goes too far many of you are familiar
with this case but nonetheless I'm sorry
to report that Suzette kilo loses the
the Supreme Court rules for the city in
this case it's a 5-4 decision the
majority opinion is written by Justice
John Paul Stevens he's since retired but
he was the leader of the courts liberal
wing at the time and Stephens writes
quote our long-standing policy of
deference to legislative judgments in
this field require the city to win he
said we cannot second-guess the
legislature he said it is up to
lawmakers and not the court to decide
quote what public needs justify the use
of the takings Clause now that is the
classic argument for judicial deference
right there if you have a complaint
about what your lawmakers have done take
it to the ballot box not to the
courthouse that's that's that's what he
told these people and and their
neighborhood is is bulldozed as a result
of this it's a highly controversial
opinion obviously in fact it was
there was bipartisan outrage against
this this decision the n-double-a-cp
filed a brief in the case on Suzette
kilo side there was a real left-right
coalition in favor of these homeowners
and against this government action but
the Supreme Court saw it differently and
invoke this this idea of deference to
lawmakers but it was the most
controversial opinion that Steven's
wrote in his long tenure and he came
under a lot of fire for writing this and
Reason magazine certainly certainly was
after him quite a bit for it and so in
2011 after he retired from the Supreme
Court he gave a speech at the University
of Alabama law school where he addressed
some of these criticisms cuz he had not
addressed the critics before he wrote a
memoir that came out that year and he
didn't talk the kilos not mentioned in
them in the mem where he talks about
other cases he's involved in he doesn't
even address this case because he
thought it was you know an open-shut win
for the government and so at this speech
Stephen said kilo was quote rooted in
justice Oliver Wendell Holmes is broad
reading of the text of the Constitution
he went on kilo quote adhere to the
doctrine of judicial restraint which
allows state legislatures broad latitude
in making economic policy decisions in
their respective jurisdictions so
there's the ghost of Oliver Wendell
Holmes you know dead a century still
haunting haunting these decisions and
you know I think it's it's safe to say
that that judicial deference in that
case failed failed these property owners
but it failed the Constitution also and
and it serves as as an example of these
these two philosophies in action that
does the Constitution require the courts
to defend defend liberty and to look
really look at what the government is
doing doesn't mean you overturn every
government action but you really look at
what's going on rather than just say
well we're going to leave it to the
lawmakers to decide if it's a public you
so we're going to trust them we're going
to put the thumb on the scale on the on
the government side rather than look is
there pretextual reasons is there is
there something else going on here and
that really is you know the libertarian
view is that's the role of the courts
that's the courts job you know John
Roberts and Obamacare said it's not our
job to protect the people from the
consequences of their political choices
and the libertarian view is it is your
job to protect
people from the consequences their
political choices when it when those
choices violate the Constitution 51% of
the voters don't you know uh just a pure
majority does not make an
unconstitutional action permissible so
that's the libertarian legal view in my
book as I said traces this debate and
looks at this and focuses on the
libertarian work that's been done and
I'll just I'll just conclude now by
saying that you know what what what this
debate really is is a fundamental
question about the nature of our system
and then sort of asks us a fundamental
question we know what sort of system
what's constitutional system do we want
to have do we want to live under you
know should the Supreme Court defer to
the will of the majority and and and
respect the will of majority and
therefore uphold most democratically
enacted laws or does the Constitution
empower the courts to act as a check on
the other branches of government and
then to act and act aggressively and act
in even an anti-democratic fashion when
when the majority has has overstepped
its boundaries and so that's I think
that is a that we can look at the
history of the Supreme Court and we can
see this debate coming up time and time
again it's its present in our current
debates the Obamacare was heard in
Supreme Court last week I was there for
that I'm sure people have questions
about that so I won't talk any more
about it this is a really fundamental
debate and it helps us understand what
the court has been up to in the past but
also helps us understand what's coming
down the line and I I think it's really
essential to understanding this this
third branch of our government and they
may be politicians but they have a lot
of power and these ideas these ideas
matter brokered thank you all very much
really enjoyed